The specific lesson objectives for this lesson are, we will look at the basics
of what we had started off in our introductory lecture, which basically talks
about how we're going to go from rays of light in a scene to pixels.
To help us understand this, what I'd like to do is first I'm
going to introduce a concept of a camera which has no optics.
And, then next thing we will look at is basically add lens and
our optics into the camera, so
we can actually start seeing what other foundational elements within a camera.
And, just to kind of provide us with the mathematical foundations, we're also
going to look at the lens equation on how light goes through a lens and where in
an image plane is it formed to create a 3-D scene on a 2-D plane of an image.